twit streamer greek god x was banned
from twitch this week after a lengthy
rant on stream in which he made
allegedly sexist comments and called out
other streamers twitch hasn't commented
on the exact reason for his ban and
greek himself says that it was simply
because he twerked on stream the whole
thing is bizarre to say the least let's
get into it
all right for some people out there this
stream rant and twitch band might be the
first time they've heard of greek god x
so who exactly is he well he's a 29 year
old variety streamer from the uk he's
been streaming for over six years on
twitch and has gained over one and a
half million followers he's best known
for his irl streams playing league of
legends and h1z1 as well as the likes of
gta 5 online and rust and i think it's
fair to say he's always been a bit of an
acquired taste as a streamer he's been
in a number of public spats with other
big streamers over the years and at one
point accused the twitch scene of being
like high school drama but anything that
happened before seems to have been
somewhat eclipsed by what happened this
week during a stream greek god x went on
a terrain about why any prospective
girlfriend of his should not be a
streamer and this goes to any women
women who want to date me especially
female streamers that want to date me
okay
if you want to date me you better
believe i will be the even if you're
streaming you're gonna have to stop
streaming streaming is ended for you
your career is done okay i will stream
while you cook for me and you clean for
me and you look after the children while
i gain all the money and i give it to
you and i give it to our children for a
healthy secure life okay that's how i
want to run my life
okay that's my life that i want to do it
now it's up to you and other people in
their other worlds whatever they want to
do but my reality i'm going to sit here
earn all the money you're going to be in
the kitchen cooking cleaning and making
sure my home is [ __ ] clean and i'm
going to make sure we have money so we
can have a home and you have a place to
sleep at night okay but is it called
working together okay
all right okay because streaming i
believe it or not is mentally damaging
to my mind we'll return to all of that
in a bit but this stream wasn't just
about that topic some of you may
remember our video where we talked about
coffeezilla accusing ice poseidon of
pulling off a crypto pump and dump
scheme well during the stream greek
conceded that what ice poseidon did was
a scam but said those who lost money
deserved it but he scammed his fans he
scammed his fans who gives a if you're
dumb enough to get scammed you deserve
it like what like
i didn't get scammed i didn't get
scammed why because i'm not [ __ ]
stupid he also took a pop at miz kiff a
streamer who he's had issues with in the
past and accused him of exposing his
young audience to only fans creators on
his stream
sorry dude this would work in miss kiss
channel because they're all like miz
kiff okay
once miss kiff can entertain a stream
about having 20 [ __ ] girls on his
stream that all have only fans with his
children viewers his child viewers not
long after that greek god x was banned
from twitch his channel and clips were
taken down many people accused greek of
being sexist and assumed that his rant
came under hateful conduct in twitch's
community guidelines which includes
encouraging discrimination on the basis
of sex but on twitter greek said that it
wasn't his words that got him banned but
that he was twerking on stream on
twitter one user replied to greek with
footage that appeared to be of the
twerking moment in question now
regardless of why exactly greek was
banned his comments stirred up a lot of
attention people were calling his
comments sexist and regressive but
others were saying he was outlining a
personal choice for himself but i do
think you've backed yourself into a
tough corner if you're trying to claim
that telling a woman what she can do
where she has to be in your house and
that she has to keep it [ __ ] clean is
anything but sexist at the very least
greek god x can't be surprised that he's
caught flack for this but that makes
absolutely no sense what he's saying
because he's saying and this goes up to
any women who want to date me you're
going to be in the kitchen which then he
tries to say
that
what he tries to do here is he's like oh
i want you to stay in the kitchen
because i don't want you to be a
streamer because streaming is bad for my
mental what he can easily just say is
i don't want to date a streamer and i
want to date a girl
who has a good job and has a good mental
because i think streaming has a mental
is mentally bad for you that's that's
the proper thing he should have said but
instead
greek had a massive incel take and then
tried to deflect it by saying that
streaming's bad for you you shouldn't do
that mischief also speculated that greek
was on something such as vivance or
adderall as a way of explaining these
takes which ms kiff says he never would
have made in years past greek got
addressed this topic on twitter by
saying that calling people manic or
saying they have a mental disorder is
damaging he then tagged reckful as an
example of why people with big audiences
should watch what they say for those who
don't know reckful was a popular
streamer who struggled with mental
health issues and whose death in 2020
was ruled a suicide calling people manic
and living giving people random mental
disorders is very damaging it's one of
the things that really affected my
friend byron and you should watch what
you say when you have a huge audience
yikes man
tagging byron in that
yikes dude some people like streamer c9
annie have been reveling in the
controversy surrounding greek god x
stating that she previously been
cancelled for talking about an
experience in which he allegedly used
her as content for his stream to [ __ ] on
her meanwhile trainwreck said he
understood where greek was coming from
when it came to toxicity within
streaming it's probably better that way
train oh for sure it's better that way
it's not probably it is
it is bro like trust me like i know
for a fact that it is
trust me like i have seen the me before
and the me now and i'm telling you there
is a major major major connection
to like happiness and well-being
when you disconnect from everything from
from all of that toxic
and asthma gold was sympathetic to grief
comments on what he wants from a
relationship i think that the only thing
that he said that was wrong
is
that you're gonna have to stop streaming
it's the implication that he would force
them to stop doing this i actually think
there's nothing wrong with what he's
asking
and if you want me to be honest like
yeah i would want to have a girlfriend
or a wife that you know she took care of
the kids my dad was able to uh you know
he had a good job and he actually uh he
gave even more money to my mom than he
had to for child support and that let
her not have to take a full-time job so
she could be around the house all the
time and take care of me and help me out
and i'd want to be able to give that to
uh to my kids in the future too
yesterday greek god x appeared to walk
back some of his previous sentiments
tweeting that he seemed to have offended
some people because quote i wanted a
traditional relationship and that if a
partner can make more money than him he
will happily cook clean and raise their
kids he also doubled down on his
anti-vaxx and only fans takes so where
does the story lie now well as with many
twitch bands we don't know exactly how
long greek is banned for only that it's
not a permaban it seems like there's a
lot of people out there who might have
been exposed to greek for the first time
from all of this and they'll either have
liked what they saw or not i guess the
only real question left now is why
exactly did twitch ban him greek said it
was because he was twerking on stream
and as strange as that might sound it
could very well be the reason we'll have
to see if greek addresses any of this
when he returns to twitch and whether or
not this drama will flare up again
you